We're here. Alhamdulillah. As you guys
know, we mentioned it before prayers
will be held here acting warpool way.
Come have a look.
Reception. Alhamdulillah.
As we come down here, this will be the
male prayer room. So for the men, they
will be able to come here pray. As you
can see now, you know the are working
hard.
Yeah. So all of this stuff here that you
see will be you know thrown away and
we're going to clean it up make it look
nice you know and suitable for the
people uh and then you know come this
way inshallah for the sisters sectional
so this is the most important part if
you ask me a lot of people have had
issues with da in the past in regards to
the sisters section here will be one
room for the sisters as you can see it's
massive you know within this room you'll
get about 50 people 50 people in this
room inshalla. Uh and this is just one
prayer vicinity room for the sisters
inshall. Now this is the bigger park.
Have a look here. Don't worry about
that. That's what I was looking for.
>> All right.
This will be the sisters section, the
main prayer pool. So here they're going
to get 100 people
100 people in this room. So 50 in that
room, 100 in this room. So that's 150
sisters in families included all within
this room in it's going to be nicely lit
up. We're going to have kitchens. It's
going to be you know painted well. We're
going to move all this stuff as you guys
know. It's going to be facilitated for
coming over here. This is also going to
be the sisters. This stuff here
will be the toilet section for the
sisters over here. We're going to have
the sisters uh and you know the
facilities here all
at this point in time being cleaned up.
Yeah. The brothers are giving it you
know that good old wax on wax sauce as
we can see to our come on come on
righteousness right kiss. So that's the
winning section. Alhamdulillah. Now once
again back into the main hall area.
Yeah. Back to the main hall area. There
will be not just prayer facilities here
but also in this room here. So come
right this way.
Uh
I believe the im will be here. The imsh
will be here.
The page Allah bless him. Uh so there'll
be more prayer facilities right here in
you guys know my pat. It's going to be
really really important. So here's one
of the papers. Ah
>> sorry. No,
>> this is a rewrite brother
>> from the D. You might have seen him
before. He's now obviously after
accepting Islam. He's building and
helping us pray. He's helping us with
the T prayers. He's our pages. He's one
of the brothers that's come true. He's
actually helping, you know, with the
procedures of what's going on. We got
another brother here. Introduce
yourself.
He's helping out. He's come so far and
haven't done that. We also got an old
school teacher. He's my teacher from
Yeah.
>> He's the man that taught me about one
before I knew anything. Yeah. You got to
admit it, but it's the truth.
>> There we go. See it there. All right.
>> We can't forget that. So for those know
our teachers are also helping building
up
the message.
>> He's pumping up. Yeah.
Yeah.
She's bush helping us out to them
immensely way more than
way more than me
too much.
from East London.
>> But I've met him all the way from East
London. All the way from East London.
He's become a West London now.
Alhamdulillah.
You might see him on Instagram. He's
doing work. Inshallah.
>> We doing work.
>> Remember, come here. Come here. Come.
Come here. This is for Allah's house. So
the work that you guys do is not my
house. His house is our house. Community
house. He's put in the work to Zak. So
if you know him on Instagram, Zakp.
And now he's doing the work of May.